♪♪♪
>>> WHAT IS THAT SOUND?
AND WHO DO I HAVE TO PAY TO MAKE
IT STOP?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M PRACTICING MY CLARINET
FOR WHEN MY COUSIN CJ GETS HERE.
>> OH YEAH.
THINK HE'LL BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE
OF OUR FISH WHEN WE GO ON OUR
BIKE RIDE TOMORROW?
>> I HOPE SO.
CJ LOVES FISH.
>> GREAT.
IN THE MEANTIME, DO YOU MIND
TAKING THAT THING OUTSIDE?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY.
HEY.
♪♪♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> MY COUSIN, CJ.
>> JOSH AND MARIO, HERE I AM.
LET'S CELEBRATE.
GOT ANY BEERS?
PERFECT.
ONE FOR YOU, FIVE FOR ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> COUSIN CJ, CAN WE ASK YOU
SOMETHING?
>> WHY NOT?
I AM YOUR COUSIN CJ AFTER ALL.
>> WHAT WE WERE WONDERING IS
WILL YOU WATCH OUR FISH WHILE WE
RIDE BIKES TOMORROW?
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'D ASK ME
THAT.
OF COURSE I WILL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪
>> LET ME GUESS, SNACKTIME FOR
MARIO?
>> AHHH!
CJ, I DIDN'T KNOW YOU WERE
THERE.
>> SORRY ABOUT THAT.
WE NEED MORE BEER.
>> WHAT ABOUT FEEDING THE FISH
TOMORROW?
>> WHO CARES.
BEER IS ALL THAT MATTERS TO ME.
>> WE'RE ALL OUT, CJ, AND THAT'S
THAT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING MARIO.
SLEEP WELL?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHY.
>> WHO CARES?
[ LAUGHTER ]
♪♪♪
>> HEY, WHAT'S GOING ON IN HERE?
>> ME AND MARIO WERE JUST
GOOFING AROUND.
RIGHT MARIO?
>> YEAH.
JUST GOOFING AROUND.
HEY, JOSH, CAN WE TALK IN
PRIVATE?
>> SURE.
>> COUSIN CJ, HE HAS BEEN
DRINKING A LOT.
AND THROWING CHAIRS AT ME.
>> OH, RELAX MARIO, HE'S JUST
HAVING FUN.
IT'S A VERY EXCITING TIME FOR
COUSIN CJ.
HE JUST GOT TO TOWN.
>> LISTEN, I DIDN'T WANT TO SAY
THIS, BUT I HAVE GOT TO TELL
YOU.
I THINK HE'S ADDICTED.
>> CJ?
♪♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S GO ON OUR BIKE RIDE.
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY, WHAT WAS I SUPPOSED TO
DO TODAY?
OH, YEAH, HAVE A BLAST.
♪♪♪
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HEY, FEEDING THE FISH WENT
GREAT.
>> YOU ARE LYING.
YOU KILLED THE FISH.
YOU USED TO BE MY HERO.
>> LEAVE ME ALONE, LOSER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
OH, NO.
I STABBED MARIO.
WHY WOULD I DO THIS?
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE ADDICTED.
ADMIT IT.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
I ADMIT IT.
I NEED HELP.
>> GREAT.
LET'S DRINK.
♪♪♪